THANKS SO MUCH FOR THAT.
WELL, UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES IN A SANE
COUNTRY WHOSE LEADERS DIDN'T
HATE IT, THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE WOULD CONDEMN THIS
KIND OF UNREST.
THE COPS THAT ROUND UP THE
PEOPLE VANDALIZING PUBLIC
PROPERTY THAT BELONGS TO ALL
OF US AND ARREST THOSE
STEALING SUBWAY RIDES.
ORDER WOULD BE RESTORED.
LIFE WOULD GO ON.
PEOPLE WOULD PAY THEIR 2.57
TO RIDE THE SUBWAY.
THIS IS AMERICA IN 2019.
ANY MOVE THAT ALMOST
PERFECTLY EMBODIES THE
ABSURDITY POLITICAL MOMENT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
CAME OUT IN FAVOR OF THE
RITE
RIOT THAT TRACE JUST
DESCRIBED.
PUNCH A COP SHE IS FOR THAT
IT'S HARD TO BE SURPRISED BY
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
A LAWMAKER SUGGESTING THAT
LAW FIRM, QUOTE,
DESTABILIZES OUR COMMUNITY
AND SIDING WITH HERMINE WHO
WANT
-NT
--T
-- WITHPEOPLE WHO WANT TO PUNCH
-- WITHPEOPLE WHO WANT TO PUNCA
COP.
YOU WONDER ABOUT THAT.
DESTABILIZING HER COMMUNITY
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
WOULD SUPPORT A FULL NYPD
WITHDRAWAL FROM HER
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT OR
MAYBE AROUND THE UPSCALE
APARTMENT BUILDING THAT SHE
LIST IN HERE IN WASHINGTON?
HUH?
JOE MURRAY IS A RETIRED NYPD
POLICE OFFICER.
HE IS RUNNING FOR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN QUEENS AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
PUNCH A COP, HUH?
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS
ENDORSING THE PUNCH A COP
MOVEMENT?
>> DISGUSTING.
I'M ALL FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
PEOPLE SHOULD EXPRESS
THEMSELVES.
WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO COMMIT
CRIMES PARTICULARLY STRIKING
POLICE OFFICERS, THAT'S
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT.
>> I AM A DEMOCRAT.
MORE CONSERVATIVE DEMOCRAT.
MOST OF MY FAMILY IS
INVOLVED IN UNIONS AND
LABOR.
AND THAT'S WHERE OUR CORE
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES COME
FROM.
I AM VERY CONSERVATIVE.
AND A LAW AND ORDER GUY AND
IN QUEENS COUNTY I AM THE
LAW AND ORDER CANDIDATE
FIGHTING AGAINST MELINDA
KATZ WHO IS THE PRESIDENT
WHO HAS ENDORSED ALL OF THIS
PROGRESSIVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM THAT MAYOR DE BLASIO
HAS BEEN TRYING TO RAM DOWN
OUR THROATS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I MEAN THIS DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE REFORM.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN LAWMAKERS
LIKE ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO, QUOTE:  PUNCH A
COP.
WHERE DOES THAT WIND UP?
>> IT'S ANARCHY.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE GOING
WITH THIS.
WE HAVE A SOCIAL CONTRACT
THAT WE, AS THE CITIZENS,
HAVE ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
ENACT LAWS AND THAT WE ELECT
OUR CHIEF EXECUTIVES TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS.
THIS IS THE SOCIAL CONTRACT
THAT CIVILIZATION IS BASED
ON.
WHEN YOU WANT TO DO IT AWAY
WITH THAT.  THAT'S ANARCHY,
ABSOLUTELY INSANE.
>> Tucker: IF YOU HAVE A
LAWMAKER AND THERE ARE AIR
QUOTES AROUND THAT,
ENDORSING VIOLENCE AGAINST
PEOPLE ENFORCING THE LAW,
THEN IT DOESN'T TAKE TOO
LONG BEFORE THINGS FALL
COMPLETELY APART, RIGHT?
>> IT REALLY IS I MEAN, I
LOOK ESPECIALLY GROWING UP,
I LOOKED AT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS, PARTICULARLY OUR
CONGRESSIONAL
REPRESENTATIVES AND FEDERAL
OFFICERS AS ROLE MODELS.
THIS IS THE STANDARD THAT WE
LOOK FOR.
THIS IS NOT WHAT WE WANT OUR
KIDS TO LOOK AT AND EMULATE.
>> Tucker: SO ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ LIVES IN A
RICH NEIGHBORHOOD IN
WASHINGTON, LIKE ONE OF THE
RICHEST, ACTUALLY.
I WONDER, DO YOU THINK THAT
SHE APPLIES THE SAME
STANDARDS TO HER OWN
NEIGHBORHOOD?
DO YOU THINK SHE WOULD LIKE
ALL THE COPS TO LEAVE
TOMORROW WHERE SHE LIVES.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
YOU KNOW THAT, TUCKER.
THIS IS ALL WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN BROOKLYN NOT AROUND HER
NEIGHBORHOOD.
CLEARLY.
THAT'S THE STANDARD.
>> Tucker: YEAH, SHE IS FOR
GUN CONTROL.
I BET YOU HER
I BET YOU TER
I BET YOU THANKFUL FOR HER
BODY GUARDS.
>> I CAN'T WAIT RETIRED
POLICE OFFICER GOING TO BE
RUNNING AGAINST AOC.
SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
THAT.
JOHN AND I TALK ALL THE
TIME.
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IN MY RACE IN
QUEENS COUNTY AND HAVING
JOHN TAKE HER SPOT WE WILL
START TO MAKE SOME CHANGES.
>> Tucker: JUST LAST
QUESTION SINCE YOU WERE A
COP FOR A LONG TIME, LIKE,
IN THE END, IT IS POOR
PEOPLE WHO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
THIS, RIGHT?
SO WHEN COPS CAN'T ENFORCE
THE LAW, RICH PEOPLE LIKE
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
LIKE SHE IS FINE.
BUT THE PEOPLE IN HER
DISTRICT, HOW DO THEY FAIR?
>> THE PEOPLE SHE IS
ENCOURAGING TO ACT LIKE THIS
AND THIS BEHAVIOR, WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO THEM
WHILE SHE GOES OFF TO
STARBUCKS WITH HER FRIENDS
AND HANGING OUT?
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
GOING TO SUFFER FROM THIS.
IT'S JUST POOR CHOICES ON
HER PART ALL THE WAY AROUND.
POOR JUDGMENT.
>> Tucker: SHE IS DUMB AND
LIKES TO THINK SHE DOESN'T